how was your session with your therapist
today she thinks that I should put
myself out there and find someone to
have sex with she didn't say the sex
part I added that I'm a weirdo that's
what everyone says
sometimes I don't know what people mean
when they say things Sam people in the
spectrum date you know girls don't
really notice me at all and I'm not
great at picking up signals she's
smiling right at you you need to turn
that down like 70% Casey
why does my to-do-list say remove stick
from butts
I don't know maybe it's on there you
guys do it right I can't from I wore
pants
Sam's gonna start dating you and I or
much holder when we met me beings time
for us to take a step back we want to
know how to get the girls I'm taking you
to poon City that's not a real place
nope not doing that there are strategies
it could teach him I'm not a little kid
anymore I can do things strategies or
when you get your heart broken sometimes
I wish I was normal dude nobody's normal
your son has the same desire to be like
that we all do rage why shouldn't he
pursue it
my family is agile everything is saying
this and autism there is time for you to
have your own life whoever first said
practice makes perfect was an idiot
humans can't be perfect because we're
not machines
the best thing that you can say about
practice is that it makes better
at some point I really really hope I get
to see boobs
[Music]